[Music]
hello everyone
we are going to continue our discussion
of the kinematics chapter
specifically we are going to continue
our discussion on the section of
quantification of uh deformation in the
previous part of the lecture we had
arrived at this equation and we had
mentioned that
we are going to mathematically
manipulate
this particular expression
that is the difference between the
displacement vectors of the point
q and the point p so
in order to motivate that
discussion let us first quickly write
down the
explicit component wise forms of
of this equation so what i basically
mean is
uh dx1 will be the capital
x1 plus q1
x1 plus d x1
x2 plus t x2
x3 plus d x3
minus u1
[Music]
x1
comma x2 comma x3
so this is just the first component of
the d small x vector
similarly we have for the small x 2
the capital x 2 plus
q 2 again a function of x 1 plus d
x 1 x 2 plus t
x2 and x3 plus
d x3 minus
q2 x1 x2
x3 and finally for the dx3 similarly we
have
d capital x 3 plus
q 3 being again a function of
capital x 1 dx plus dx 1
x 2 plus dx2 x3
plus x3 minus
q3 x1 x2
x3 so this was quite repetitive and
i'm sure quite boring but uh anyway the
benefit of having written
out uh explicitly like this is basically
to motivate
that if you just look at one component
let's say dx1
equivalently dx2 you see this is
basically this part this entire part
the difference between the two position
vectors or the first component of the
position vectors u1 here and u1 here
this is basically a function of three
variables
this also is a function of three
variables but
the functional dependence is in such a
form that here it is x one
here is x one plus d x one so by a small
increment a difference by a small
increment
it is x 2 it is x 2 by x 2 plus d x 2
and here it is x 3 and a this is exactly
x 3 plus d x 3. so in each of
these three component wise dependencies
there is only a small increment
perhaps this gives us an idea that it
will be beneficial to expand this
using taylor series expansions but the
only problem is that from our previous
lessons of taylor series expansions what
we are mostly familiar with
um i'm sure is
uh the taylor series expansions of
functions
which have only uh one uh one kind of
functional dependence
so what we are going to do very quickly
here is a brief refresher of taylor
series expansions
so first of all if we have
something like f of x plus dx
and please note that from uh in this
little refresher on taylor sales
expansion whenever i'm going to write
this small x it has no connection
whatsoever with these previous
dependencies this is just
a general uh mathematical dependence
so this is just like your first in
mathematics so
f of x plus d x that is given by
f of x plus
d x by factorial one
first derivative of f of x with respect
to
x uh
plus e x square
divided by factorial 2 f
double dash x plus
higher order terms this we are all
familiar with but suppose now
we have instead of the dependence on
only x plus dx suppose we have
uh some kind of a dependence on another
variable
y so suppose
we have a thing like this x plus d x
y plus d y then what
well
for the first term as you can imagine
this will be just
the f dependent on x and y
and then we'll again have
the first order term like this but now
instead of the f dash x we have to
remember that
because f is a function of both x and y
the uh the derivative of f with respect
to x has to be taken in the form of a
partial derivative so
this is del f del x
but the but the dependence on y also has
to be accounted for
and that is done by writing it exactly
like the dx part
so this is d y by factorial y del f
del y so this is the first order term
for the next order
we can have dx square
by factorial 2
[Music]
and this time we have del square f
del x square
and we have
y squared by factorial 2
however this is not the end of the story
because
uh we'll also have some kind
of a cross dependence involving both the
dx and dy because this is
now a quadratic dependence so
it will be
twice d x
d y by factorial 2
[Music]
del square f del x
del y plus we are going to have
some higher order terms
all right now you can see that slowly we
are
building up to our dependence on three
variables
and that will be useful to us when we go
back towards the simplification
of these displacement vector components
so
we can write down the the
three dependencies uh
going forward to x plus d x y plus d y
and uh z plus d z
in the next slide
this is the thing that we have extra
here dz by factorial 1
del f del z now if i want
i can possibly go to the second order
terms
but i don't want to do that because
remember
that my purpose here of doing all this
this brief refresh on the taylor series
expansion
is to actually mathematically manipulate
this
and for that purpose i do not need to
consider these higher order terms
so all that i want is to go up to the
linear or the first order terms so i'll
stop the
the writing out of the terms up to here
and by comparing this f of x plus d x y
plus d y
z plus t z with the u one
for example uh as it depends on x one
plus d x one
x two plus d x two x three plus d x
three i can
uh write down
the taylor series expansion of this term
okay so
going back to the dx1 component
if i take a look at this again
so this thing
will be expanded in exactly this fashion
so what do we write here u1
x1 x2
x3 plus
the x1 and i do not anymore right
divided by factorial 1 because that is
just 1
and del u1
del x1 you please note the similarity of
this term
with this term
okay so going forward
dx2 del u1
again del
x2 again you know the similarity of this
with this
and please be very careful to note that
this is still u1 here
because we are going to we are actually
dealing with
the expansion of this
u1 here this entire thing this is
completely separate the u2 and the u3
are completely separate
okay and finally we have
d x 3 del
u 1 then x 3
plus dot dot dot and
please do not forget that we have this
term remaining
at the end the u1 x1 comma x2 comma x3
we have to write that down also
you see very quickly that this term
it cancels with this term so
that's very nice and we end up with
a very nice convenient form
which can be written in a very nice
clear way
in operator form like this
that entire thing goes in a bracket
and that entire thing like an operator
it operates on the variable u1
and of course we have the higher order
terms here which i'm not going to write
anymore
so what you can say is that
the dx1 because i'm no longer writing
the higher order terms
this is no longer an equal to so
this is now the taylor series expand
expansion of the taylor series
approximation
for the d small x1 in a similar fashion
if i go back and look at my dx2
we'll note that i have to expand in
terms of this u2 and
i can directly write that down
as dx2 is approximately equal to
the capital x2 plus
this entire operator will remain as it
is
but this time this is going to operate
on u2
and similarly for the x3
i will again have this to be
approximately equal to
the x3 plus this entire operator again
dx1 del del x1
plus e x 2
l del x 2
plus e x 3
l x 3 operating
this time on u3
now you note that this entire operator
uh it is convenient and it can be
written in a further uh
in a still more compact form by noting
that
this is almost like uh so let me write
this down quickly
so this operator uh
x1
so this thing
is like the dot product
between the d expected and
the gradient operator
well that was that seems like a massive
leap but actually it's very simple so
we can quickly note it down in the rough
column here
that
the d expected that has the components
dx1 dx2
and dx3 so these are the three
components of the dx vector
and the gradient operator
that is nothing but having the
different components as del del x 1
del del x 2 delta
x 3 so
i hope you can remember this from your
first year vector calculus
so if we substitute this particular
expression
back here then this becomes even more
simple
so the small x1
is equal to
e capital x1 plus
the expected
dot grad
u1 similarly
d x 2 is equal to
the capital x 2
plus the x vector
plotted with the grad operator operating
on
u2 and finally dx3
is equal to d capital
x3 plus the
x vector sorted with the grad operator
on this now all these three three things
together
they can be further shortened into the
vectorial representation as this because
you note
that dx1 dx2 and dx3
they are themselves components of this
the small x vector
similarly the d capital x 1 the capital
x 2 and d capital x 3
they are the components of the d
capital x vector which we have already
written here
plus this is already in vector form
red this entire operator
is operating on the vector u
because you note that q1 u2 and u3
are nothing but the scalar components of
this new vector
so this is a very very useful very
compact
notation that helps us to go forward
with the quantification
of deformation
okay so in the next part of our lecture
we are going to see how
these of this expression
which incorporates within it three
different expressions
uh these can be utilized
in the context of our discussions on
stream which will be a major major topic
within our chapter
of kinematics thank you